I love British comedy
but their Wellness centered reality TV
could not be more problematic and the
scandalous secret eaters is no exception
as the name implies the premise of the
show is to essentially catch
participants eating in secret by hiring
undercover investigators to expose the
true reason for someone's unexplained
weight gain participants are later
confronted in a caught you in the ACT
moment solving the big mystery of why
they're fat get your TV dinners in the
microwave my lovelies and buckle up for
a ride because more than ever there's a
lot to unpack hey everyone I'm Abby
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
thank you
in today's video we'll be talking about
controversial British reality series
secret eaters But first you can pause
the screen or look at my description to
check out my disclaimer and Trigger
warning we will be discussing some very
problematic diet behaviors and
recommendations and there may be
calories on screen at some points so
please feel free to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey and
if you are not already subscribed smash
that sub button and follow me on Tick
Tock and Instagram at Abby's kitchen so
for starters what exactly is secret
eating how common is it and ultimately
why do we do it in short secret eating
involves eating at times in locations or
in ways where you won't be seen with the
intention of hiding what or how much
you're eating from others considering
that survey data suggests 60 of women
engage in secret eating at times and at
least a quarter attempt to hide the
evidence there's a good chance that a
lot of you watching have done this at
some point in your your life maybe
you've waited until your spouse went to
bed to have that last slice of cake or
you've consumed Mass amounts of diet
foods in secret to avoid eating out with
friends maybe you eat McDonald's for
lunch every day and then like air out
the car of that fresh fry smell before
getting home I mean leave me a comment
below with your experience now while
secret eating is not an official eating
disorder experts believe that it may be
a symptom or precursor to the
development of a full Ed I'm going to go
into detail into why you may be secretly
eating in a moment but let's unpack
secret eaters groundbreaking solution
first thousands of us are mysteriously
gaining weight is that the heaviest
you've ever been yeah things just aren't
adding up some days I don't have enough
food or are they and it looks like we've
been doing a lot more than telling
porcupines are you aware of how much
you're eating
we'll get there oh
how many people sat in a boardroom and
thought hey yeah this would be like a
really nice idea for a show let's break
down Why shows like this do more harm
than good number one it food chains
participants obviously okay so this show
may actually perpetuate secret eating
through intense shame judgment and
embarrassment as they broadcast some
pretty undignified footage of
participants to the whole effing World
behind us here we've got our
surveillance board check that out
the chocolate bar hanging out your dog
in the garage
oh I've got no idea how much I was
eating I don't think I really realized
just how much I was sort of packing Away
really that's a lot of things it's not
even nine o'clock yet is it
no empathy no compassion no
evidence-based counseling skills just
ruthless humiliation for the sake of
hate watching views we talked about this
ad nauseam in my reviews of my 600 pound
life and 1 000 pound sisters but all
this ends up doing is perpetuating fat
phobia for entertainment purposes which
brings me to my next Point shows like
this contribute to weight-based
stereotypes this show portrays folks in
larger bodies as lazy lacking willpower
and being out of control with food on
top of that the show's entire premise is
to essentially portray participants as
deceptive Liars AKA possessing one of
the worst character flaws that there is
sometimes I'll have a big breakfast but
then that'll be it for the whole day yep
that will be it for the day
until 20 minutes later we're in a
supermarket according to his food diary
he usually has a salad at this time
maybe he decided to go out for a salad
today
[Music]
hmm doesn't look like a salad shop like
I'm getting mad more polish Vibes with a
lie detector determined that was a lot
but here we have the embedded negative
association that fat people are like
liars and one of the ways in
which the show essentially sets these
participants up for failure is by
relying on a food diary or Diet recall
diet recalls are notoriously subject to
error participants either forget or
intentionally embellish their diets when
they know that they're being judged or
assessed Sarah's food dive said she was
eating around 1 220 calories a day but
she ate nearly 700 a day in snacks alone
that combined with a big roast potato
habit and some fast food lunches help
take up her real daily average to a
whopping 4 350 calories it's not just
larger body people who do this we all
tend to do this when explicitly being
judged the show relies on this ingrained
tendency of most humans because if it
weren't for recall bias there would
never be this outrageous caught you kind
of aha moment the truth is larger body
folks typically know which foods they
should or shouldn't be eating Society
just doesn't let them forget so this is
usually not the reason for secret eating
but instead of diving into these complex
psychosocial factors this show makes it
seem like this is some kind of inherent
character flaw and speaking of
Personality Jabs let's talk about the
completely inappropriate unprofessional
name calling on the show so not only is
the show Rife with truly abhorrent
diculture language across the board just
remember Katie chicken wings today
equals bingo Wings tomorrow but
participants are typically given a whole
host of negatively charged labels based
on their eating habits she's a classic
confused calorista Tracy is a classic
delusional Drinker I'm sorry I get that
alliterations are cute but calling some
someone delusional because they
overestimate their calorie intake seems
a bit harsh I was disrespectful these
are real people with real Lives who are
in a vulnerable place seeking help and
guidance the last thing they need is the
so-called professional addressing them
in such undignified and condescending
ways like I'm truly mortified that they
have a dietitian involved in this show
but this brings me to my last issue and
that is that shows like this exclusively
reduce obesity to a big fat you problem
that you need to fix yes of course we
are the masters of our own body we have
the autonomy to make certain choices
over others and yes knowledge is
absolutely part of making those choices
more obvious which I believe is what
this show is trying to suggest but
obesity is a lot more complex than just
choosing an apple over chips because
you've learned that the apple is a
healthier choice genetics food security
age hormones medical conditions
medications mood disorders sleep stress
and much more all play a role in why
some people end up at the extreme end of
the weight Spectrum but I've yet to come
across of an episode where the show
tries to investigate why participants
eat in secret instead the goal is to
portray them as sneaky dishonest or
stupid to food chain them and to offer
up surface level advice that most of
them probably already know in fact in
one of the episodes where they
identified the participant as an
emotional eater their advice was simply
to ignore Cravings not helpful if you're
an emotional eater remember Cravings
only last about 20 minutes so distract
yourself until the urge to eat passes
but if you take anything away from this
problematic show it may be an indicator
of your own secret eating maybe you see
some of your behaviors in the Katies
johns or Laura's who for some reason
sign up for this torture oh my God a
tortured artist I love that and since
the show made zero effort to educate the
public on the reasons for secret eating
you might be wondering about your why
and what you can do to stop so why are
we so prone to want to eat alone in
secret number one to cope with
uncomfortable emotions they eat for
Comfort every single turn to is food for
everything whether I'm happy sad
anything I'll turn to food occasionally
eating to self-soothe difficult emotions
is totally normal we just want to make
sure it's not our only coping mechanism
or that it's not impacting our physical
and mental well-being with that said
emotional eating can actually fuel
secretive eating with one study
suggesting that secret eating was
associated with depression anxiety anger
and low self-esteem those with
depression were five times more likely
to eat in secret now big emotions are
still somewhat Taboo in our stiff upper
lip kind of society so it's not
surprising that a lot of folks May we
try to conceal the evidence out of fear
of being judged which brings us to
reason number two to avoid food or body
shaming and judgment research suggests
that folks who eat in secret are more
likely to report weight concerns for
instance once that he found that
secretive eating is more common in folks
in larger bodies who report feeling a
loss of control around food another
study found that secretive eating often
occurs in response to body shaving I
mean no Sherlock folks in larger bodies
have experienced a lifetime of
unsolicited advice about their body and
food choices just look at the comments
on this app whenever someone in a larger
body has so much as a piece of bread
like no wonder you'd want to hide in the
bathroom and eat alone now we typically
don't see the same food heckling with
folks in smaller bodies on this app I
mean most thin girls doing mukbangs or
massive cheat days are celebrated and
therefore not only have the confidence
to eat a burger in public but they're
emboldened to do do it for millions of
people online I went into a lot more
detail on that in my amberlin read video
right here but that brings me to the
role of our childhood so I dive deeper
into the connection between childhood
food experiences and disordered eating
in my video right here but with the
trend of discussing almond moms
ingredient only households and other
potential childhood food traumas on Tick
Tock it's relevant to be reminded of how
parents relationships with food and our
bodies can influence those of their kids
and unfortunately secret eating can be a
byproduct of being exposed to disordered
parental eating habits early on in
childhood for example one five-year
prospective study found that secret
eating in children was associated with
maternal body dissatisfaction
internalization of the thin ideal and
dieting so in other words when parents
die in front of their kids or restrict
kids of access to certain foods they
will find a way to seek them out in
private like who else remembers that
super political incorrect 1995 movie
heavyweights with Ben Stiller when the
kids at the fat camp were like hiding
chocolate bars under their bed I behind
chocolate bars too if my parents shipped
me off to a militant fat camp so
obviously we've established that secret
eaters is a dumpster fire of a show that
does nothing to empathize with or
improve the lives of these 60 of adults
who apparently engage in secret eating
it does nothing to help support
individuals find ways to end this
Behavior so if you're wondering what to
do about your secret eating here are
some super quick tips number one be kind
to yourself judgment and shame typically
only contributes to the cycle of secret
eating so remember that foods are not
good not bad and you are not good or bad
for choosing certain foods number two
develop other coping strategies to
emotional eating as we've established
secret eating and emotional eating are
intimately intertwined so if we find
more effective coping mechanisms for our
emotional eating Tendencies we're better
able to nip the secret eating at the
source next develop responses to food
shaming I actually have a whole video of
sassy ass responses when people are
share hearing unsolicited advice about
your body or what's on your plate so
strike a power pose stand in front of
your mirror and practice those responses
to those triggering scenarios the more
prepared and confident you are standing
up for your choices to others the less
desire you'll feel to need to hide them
and finally speak to a professional a
dietitian and therapy team can be
essential to helping you get to the root
cause of your secret eating so please do
reach out to a professional if you can
and on that note I hope you guys can
agree that shows like secret eaters are
toxic as the fact that this show ran for
a whole three seasons just reinforces
how much people just love to hate watch
fat people get ridiculed and shamed but
somehow we're like 10 years since the
show launched and I can't say that we've
made many more games but I would love to
hear your thoughts on the show and if
you yourself have suffered from Secret
eating now or in the past and if you
like this video please don't forget to
give it a thumbs up leave me a comment
below on who or what you'd like to see
me review next subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]